- Bonsoir, Mesdames,
Mesdemoiselles et Messieurs.
- Le 11 octobre 1952,
les joueurs du Canadien
de Montréal vont aéal vont appae
pour la première fois
à la télévision.
- Jamais il me semble,
nos commanditaires n'auraient
pu choisir meilleure partie
pour nos débuts à la télévision.
- Comme l'explique l'historien
du hockey Carl Lavigne,
on ne diffusait à l'époque
que la troisième période.
- Et ça y est, la troisième
période est en marche.
CARL LAVIGNE,
historien du hockey- On se regri
qui avait la télé et on écoutait
le match de hockey, qui,
on le sait, commençait très tard
donc en troisième période.
À l'époque, on avait cette peur
que la télévision vienne nuire
à la vente de billets.
- Howe, le 9 et Howe, même chose
pour le Canadien : 9, Richard.
- La description de René
Lecavalier va donner le ton aux
matchs de hockey en inventant
un nouveau vocabulaire
en français, qui fera école.
- Messieurs Richard et Sinclair
se font de mauvaises mines.
- À l'époque, les jeunes
René Pothier et Pierre Houde
regardaient ces ma
une petite télévision en noir
et blanc sans se douter
qu'un jour, ils marcheraient sur
les traces du célèbre animateur.
PIERRE HOUDE, descripteur
matchs de hockey de la LNH (RDS)
- Mes souvenirs vont souvent
dans le sens de René Lecavalier
qui nous accueiller,
Mesdames, Messieurs. Eh, bien,
c'est 4 à 0 pour le Canadien."
Et là, on disait : Ce n'est pas
vrai! On a manqué quatre buts!
(rires)
- Rebonsoir, tout le monde.
Eh bien, pendant que le Canadien
se heurte à une équipe tenace...
RENÉ POTHIER, ancien descripteur
La soirée du hockey Radio-Canada
- Cet homme-là a inventé,
vraiment, là, inventé
un lexique canadien-français,
c'est ce qu'on disait
à l'époque, du hockey.
C'était un tour de force inouï.
- Bel arrêt de Giacomin
r de Lemaire.
Et... Oh là! Eh bien, c'est
un magicien, ce gardien.- René e
des expressions et lorsqu'elles
taient utilisées, il biffait
ces expressions dans son carnet
pour éviter de les
trop souvent.
- Derrière ces buts, Kelly
joue à cache-cache.
- Les premières prises de vue
irée des matchs de la
Soirée du hockey étaient faites
avec trois caméras.
Durant 20 ans, Jacques Primault
en a été le réalisateur. Il a vu
la télévision évolst
lui qui captera des images
qui resteront dans les annales
de l'histoire du hockey.
JACQUES PRIMEAU, ex-réalisateur
La soirée du hockey Radio-Canada
- C'était trois caméras qui
étaient fixes. Tu n'avais pas
de lentilles pour faire
ce qu'on appelle un "zoom in"
dans le gardien puis tout ça.
Aujourd'hui, chaque caméra
a une fonction.
- La caméra portative derrière
les buts permet deter
tous les aspects du jeu.
- En 70 ans d'histoire,
le hockey à la télévision a
bien évolué. Certains pourrontsé
à la naissance d'une tradition,
d'autres feront en sorte
de la perpétuer.
Ici Robert Frosi,
Radio-Canada, Mon